my name is Massimo Moratti I am an
assistant professor in group operation
information and technology in its
Graduate School of Business at Stanford
University I worked two years as postdoc
in Microsoft Research and there I worked
on hospital readmissions that means we
use hospital data they hospitals that
work with Microsoft and use Microsoft's
offer to tackle hospital readmission
problem we worked with algorithms that
extract information from large amount of
data and we went to the hospital and
said what problems you have that we
could actually leverage the data that
it's already collected the tackle and
they mentioned hospital readmission to
us when a patient is discharged from the
hospital and then the patient comes back
in a short amount of time say in 30 days
it's called hospital readmission and
this is actually a big problem about
twenty percent of Medicare patients
return to the hospital in a short amount
of time and they estimated the cost of
that those readmissions to Medicare is
about 17 billion dollars just in one
year one might say okay if a patient
comes back that could be okay that would
be just an accident or some other
condition but in fact the same study
indicated majority of the admissions are
because of the problem that wasn't
addressed properly in the first visit
now with the government measures they
are essentially incentivize and they
have to do something about it otherwise
they'll be penalized and this has
generated a lot of activity in this
space the difficulty here is which
patients would need the interventions
animals so we designed an algorithm that
sifts through hundreds of thousands of
patient records from the past and finds
patterns based on these patterns you
would know which patient is riskier than
the other ones and then we would pick
those patient up and says okay this
patient needs an intervention for this
patient you need to send a pharmacist to
their own for this patient you might
need to just have a follow-up phone call
and this is a very
doctors because these are just
recommendations looks for things that
they might miss I think there are about
dozens of hospitals that are currently
using the system and even there's about
maybe 10 startup companies who are
trying to build readmission prediction
solutions and some of them are being
implemented so I already see a boom in
this space that companies are trying to
leverage data and tackle problems such
as readmission so readmission is one
problem there are other problems in
healthcare that can be addressed using
data analysis giving early intervention
recommendations to the physicians for
very significant various adverse events
these are automated real-time score
generations and the new techniques that
are essentially used for data analysis
are more powerful and produce very
accurate results
you